適在適書、本人の支出と仕事をちゃんと
当ててあげるっていうことと、そしてそれ
が精神的報酬だけじゃなくて経済でも
ちゃんと還元してあげること。つまり感謝
を報酬で表すってこと。至らない自分を
支えてきてくれ[音楽]てありがとう。
その感謝から全てが生まれてくる。
[音楽]青木サの人生学100回聞いたら
豊かになる話。今回はですね、え、人材
獲得競争が、ま、激化し続けていると今
思うんですけれども、ま、会社によっては
ですね、給料とかポジションとか、ま、
対遇で優秀層を引き止めようとする会社も
、ま、多いかなという風に思うんです
けれども、ま、青木社長はアチーブメント
はそうではない比較的あの傾向もあるのか
なと思っていまして、ま、青木社長は優秀
層の本当の欲求や、ま、何を1
番その彼らが求めているのかということについてどんな風に考えているのか教えていただけますでしょうか?
うん。
俺多分ね、自分自身が不完全というか、
まだまだ力不足だなということを自覚し
ながら謙虚にみんなに力を借りながら
絶対にいい会社にしたい。将来はこういう
会社にしていきたい。こういうことを実現
したいんだっていうことをなんだろう。
紳摯にみんなの声を聞きながら頑固に
なんかこう押し付けるんではなくて一緒に
なんかこう会社を作るっていう
感覚多分うちの社員の幹部クラスで優秀
な人間はみんな持ってるような気がする。
どう思うそれ?
あ、でもそれはすごいありますね。あるよ
な。うん。うん。うん。
なので15
年かけてやっぱりこう本当にその会社をま、なんて言うんでしょうね。一緒に良くしてきたなというところだったりですとかなんか共にやろうよっていう声をかけ続けてくださいましたし逆に言うとその会社もな
んて言うんでしょう。
なんか人間としてより大きくなるっていうことをなんかこう育む支援をずっとし続けてくださったなと思っていってなのでそのなんて言うんでしょう?他の会社に入社してたら多分もっとやなやつに私なってただろうなっていうことは
[笑い]
すごい思いやいやいや
すごい思いですけどうん
なんかそういやそのなんかそのなんて言うんでしょうね俺も不完全だからみんなで力を差し出し合おうねって言ってくださるのと同じくらい逆に
とこ私たちの不なところに対してもなんて言うんでしょう?すごくこう受け止めてくださってまだからみんなで良くなろうよっていう
なんかそういうこう
人が育ちながらこう会社が良くなり続けるっていう循環をなんか回す面白さをなんか教えてくださったなっていうのはすごい思いますね。
うん。なるほどね。まあなんだろうな。
自分の人生振り返ってみても結局
個人としてもすごい不完全な自分が一生
懸命努力してなんだろういろんなもう書籍
を区の書籍の影響も受け尊敬する先輩の
影響も受けま本当に勉強しながらま気が
ついたらアメリカにも20回以上研修に
行ったりいろんなことしながら全てに意味
があったんだと思うんだよね。だから感謝
なんだよ。だから感謝が湧き上がるんです
よ。至らない自分を支えてきてくれて
ありがとうってその感謝から全てが生まれ
てくる。結局
好きな人と好きなことを好きなだけできる
人生。ま、結局好きな人とっていうことは
仲間だろうな。経営者であり仲間、あとお
客さんに対する共感やっぱり大きいよね。
そして好きなこと、この職業に対する共感
ね。好きな時に好きなだけっていうのは
これちょっと老期法もあるから好きなだけ
できなくごめんねってことなんだけどでも
本当はそういう意味では自由5つの基本的
欲求が満たされる職場作りを本当に真剣に
追求してきたからま結果的に今のような
会社になったのかなと思うけどね。だ、俺
もやっぱり人間って完璧、完全じゃないと
思ってるんで、不完全な人間同士が向上心
を持って助け合いながら良い組織を作っ
てくのが、ま、実態だと思ってるので、だ
、僕は社員には不平、不満はないですよ。
もっといい会社にしていきます。いや、
もっと言うと社員に負荷をかけるよりも
売れる商品もっと考えよう。もっと行列が
ならできる。それこそね、なんだろう。
ま獣を作るとしたらもうすぐ売り切れて
しまう。うまい饅じ作ろう。社員のその
働きに不満持つんじゃなくて自分は
うまい饅じ作れていない自分の修行が足り
ないとそう思うなんだよ俺は。うん。だ
からもっともっと
ね、いい研修を作ろう。もっともっと顧客
が満足してくれる圧倒的競争優位に立つ
商品を作ろう。
そこだけやっていったら社員を逆に楽させてあげられるのかなと思って頑張るし、それそういう心志しを持った人間を社長に次ようと思ってます。
ま、今のお話の中にもかなりあったんですけれども、ま、いわゆる優秀層素層とかハイパフォーマンっていうのがやりが感じ続けるために、ま、必要なことというか、なんかこう来ないことやめてくことを投げくのではなくって、その人たちにやりがいを感じ続けてもらうために、いや、こういうことすべきでしょうっていう青木とのお考えてお聞かせていただいてますか?
正解わかんないけど、僕は何を転が分けてやってきたかっていうことだけ話すと適材的書本人の支出と仕事をちゃんと当ててあげるってい
っていうことと、もう1つはフェアである
こと。公平高成な人事制度。そして若くて
も材料が与えられる。ちゃんとその認めて
あげること。そしてそれが精神的報酬だけ
じゃなくて経済でもちゃんと還元して
あげること。つまり感謝を報酬で表すって
こと。だからなんだろう。その今高い報酬
を払えてない会社もあると思うんだよね。
このYouTube見てくれてるお客さん
の中には。でもそこを目指しているのか
社員の働き方や社員の能力がないからこれ
以上これしか利益出せないんだっていう
考え方を持っているのかは月とぽ本ぐらい
違うんだよ。
あくまでもやっぱりこの経営者の企業料というか、経営者自身がどういう考え方を持って慶するかで会社の未来変わると思うし、そこがやっぱり伝わってるんだよね。だから伝わったら必ず社員っていうのはその期待にえようとするし、や、自分たちがいい会社を作りますと。
うん。だからよく僕が言ってきたことだ
けどね。うちの会社とよその会社は何が
違うか。一般的な企業ってあなたの給料は
誰が決めるって言ったらはい。人事が決め
ますとかうちの会社が決めますっていう。
でもうちの会社ではね、アチューメントで
はあなたの給料やあなたのポジションは誰
が決めるてったらはい。私の働き方が私の
報酬やポジションを決めてますというこの
違いだと思う。これだけちゃんと大事にし
てれば能力のある人間は伸びノびと
どんどん伸びてくと思います。
ま、だからシンプルに言えば人ってさ、
生きてる人の数だけ欲求の満たし方違うの
で私は選択だから選択なんね。1つの基本
的欲求が満たされる職場環境を目指して
改革をしてきたっていう表現がいいな。
その最初からそうだったわけじゃないので
。でも5つの基本欲求が満たされる生存愛
と所属力自由楽しみ。この5つの基本欲求
が満たされる組織運営の中で優秀層は
やっぱりなんだろう。その自分自身の才能
能力を思う存分発揮して社会をよりよくし
ていく心志しまた報われる。ちゃんとそれ
が世の中への貢献と自分のプライベートの
面でもちゃんと満たさ満たされる会社で
働き続けるんだと思う。だからそれを
やっぱり相手の立場に立って考えながら、
ま、相手の望みを叶えることを自分の望み
とするという経営を私は心がけてきました
。何事でも人々からして欲しいと望む通り
のことを他の人々にもそのようにしなさい
と。ま、マタ7章12節にある。その言葉
を大事に私は形用してきたので、これから
もこれは僕の人生の土台なので変わること
はない。ま、そしてこういう僕の考え方に
共感する人材を大切にこれからもしていき
たいという風に思ってます。決して、え、
お金やその体遇やそういう目先のなんか
こう馬の花の頭に人参ン大きい方が
モチベーションが高くなって遠いより近い
方がいいみたいなそういう発想で社員を見
てきたことはない。そうするとこれ失礼に
なるんですよ。侮辱されてるっていうか
褒美で釣るみたいな。そうじゃないもんね
。だからもしそうだったとしたら、ま、瞳
も早期も今ここにはいないと思うんだよね
。だからやっぱりこうこの人変わってるな
となんでこんなストイックに不満足な人間
関係が禁するあらゆる不幸をこの世から
撲滅するとわけのわかんないことをいつも
言っていじめ差別のない明るい社会作るん
だとこんなになんで純粋に走れるんだろう
とかじゃあどういう風な仕組みにしたら
それが社長の望みが叶えられるのかとか
商品こうしようとかっていうことで考えて
くれてるわけじゃん。なんかこう創業の時
に利益は目的な結果であると満足より喜び
より幸福売るんだとね。リタに撤し事故を
愛せよっていう射税作ったんだけど社員5
名温金500万の時作ったんだよな。でも
結果今その言葉に僕生きてるよね。うん。
それに共感した人材が大幹部になってる
ような気がする。ま、だから経営はぶれず
に自分の心志しを遂げていったらいいん
じゃないですか。え、是非ね、あの
コメント何かあればコメントの方よろしく
お願いします。あとはあのハイプ是非ね、
え、新機能ですので応援してください。高
評価とチャンネル登録もお忘れなく。全国
9箇所回って今講演してます。恐怖を
築づく思法。是非リアル会場でおめにたい
と思います。次回のYouTubeでまた
会いましょう。ありがとうございます。
それこそ優秀層の筆頭の淵口に聞きたいわ
。岡口は何を求めてるんだよっていうのが
僕のタイプよ。あ、早期に聞きたいわ。
早期は何を求めてるの?早期は何を求め
てんの?この会社で参考まで聞かう
例えばですけど私[鼻息]が新卒だった頃
に
うん。
ま、頭文字だけ同じですけど、アチューメンツともう
1社、ま、IT
テックの会社とで悩んでいる時期に
最終的に意思決定した理由は
報酬だけを見るともう
社だったんですが報酬だけではなくて自分がこのせっかく
回切りの人生の時間を使うんだとしたら何に使いたいのかなと考えた時に自分はやっぱり教育をやりたい
うん。ていうのが1番だった。
うん。
そして教育の中でも、ま、いろんな会社あると思うんですが、選択心理学やアチーメント、テクノロジーに基づいた教育をするのであれば、アチーメント以外の選択肢がなかった
というのが、ま、入社理由ですし、今も変わらない
働き続けている理由なので、報酬は今かなりいいてる認識があるんですが、それ以上にこの仕事っていうか、ま、仕事とも思ってないというか、これがやりたいのでやっているっていう
[咳払い]
ただそれだけなのかなと。
うん。[咳払い]
仕事が面白いですし、やりたいことである
ていうのが
うん。
あ、究極なのかなと。
なるほど
思います。
やっぱり優秀だな。素晴らしい。はい。瞳。
私も答えんです。
うん。そうよ。参考までに。
参考までにですね。[鼻息]
いや、でも参考までに、ま、でも本当にあの、中島君言ってるのと本当に似てしまうんですけれども結局私もま、え、入社の時もそうですし、あの、年間休日が
日くらいある会社から、あの、泣いていただいていたりとかみたいなのもこう色々ある中で、当時多分アチーブメントって、あの、これ出せるかわからないんですけど、多分あの、月のお休みが
[咳払い]
7日で年間休日
桁みたいなことだったりとか、ま、なんか色本当にその条件面、大宮面で考え
うん。
おというとま、あっ
そうですね。15
年前ですからね。はい。色々あったんですけれども。
うん。うん。うん。
ただ、ま、もちろんそのなんて言うんでしょう?健全にそのなんて言うんでしょうね。経済的な豊かさを全部置いてえでもなんて言うんでしょう。こう仕事に全てをかけるタイプでもなかったので当然その両立中でやっぱり
回の人生で自分の人生をかけてでもやりたいことを仕事でやりたいな。
なっていうのはもうすごくあったので自分が人生かけるに値する仕事かなっていうのはすごく大事にし続けて、ま、今もあのここにいるのかなというのはすごく思いますね。
うん。なるほどな。
はい。全国の皆さん、是非会場でおめに帰りましょう。